[موسيقى]
بلدي محتله ومن حق اي مواطن عراقي عندما
يحتل بلده ومن حقه مواطن يقاوم الاحتلال
بشتى الوسائل فكان يتواصل نعم مع يعني بعض
فصائل المقاومه العراقيه وهو في الاسر وهو
في الاسر نعم كانوا يستشيروه حتى ببعض
الامور يعني يطلبون عنده توجيه كان يحصل
عبرك فقط
من خلال جلسات
من خلال لقاءات ومع اخرين
[موسيقى]
وتمرر له بعض المعلومات يعني بصيغه مشفره
او بصيغه غير مفهومه يعني اغلب الامور
اللي تمر الا بطريقه مشفره كان يلتقط ذلك
مباشره
يعني يعرف عن ذلك يعلن عن ذلك في خلال
المحاكمات ذكي جدا هو بالجانب التشفير ذكي
جدا يعني في بعض الاحيان كان في بعض
المصطلحات اللي يستخدمها مثلا في خلال
محاكماته يكون قصدها على انها شيفره مثلا
يدعوهم للصمود او يدعوهم المقاومه واحيانا
يقول هلا بصريح العباره
قوات المسلحه المجاهده وكان القاضيه نبهه
يعني كانت الامور علانيه بشكل صريح وامور
اخرى مشفره
[موسيقى]